hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna do a
little podcast for you today is the top
award to your video request from Omni
Media has an awesome YouTube channel
seriously guys you I'm not joking go
check out his channel it's fantastic I
can't believe he's a supporter of ours
when you're super rich and famous I hope
you're still supporting our patreon page
good for you we will not be oh yeah but
more more so more so you better double
triple your pledge just raise your
pledge along with your income
proportionately he wanted us to talk
about he said let's do serial
storytelling versus non sir analyzed so
light shows like arrow versus shows like
Twilight Zone uh-huh okay
that's fascinating well there's like
kind of three categories to me there's
the episodic television I mean
technically all shows are at Masonic but
there's the episodic time programming
usually comedies sitcoms like on network
TV friends Seinfeld that have its
connective tissues but generally you can
kind of just hop in at any point and go
check it out there's those and then also
like the anthology shows like black
mirror which are extremely episodic and
there's no real tie ends or Twilight
Zone and then there's the the light ones
that you recalling shows like arrow or
flash a lot of those CW shows or even I
think like manda will see how the
Mandalorian ends and um it's been pretty
episodic with some serial elements yeah
so there's like that middle ground where
technically they're all tied but for the
most part they feel episodic and
separate and then there's the you know
defining serialized TV which is really
marked the golden age of television
shows like you know Breaking Bad Game of
Thrones and it seems like like the cable
and streaming have really opened that up
and even though black mirror has reached
so much of its fame through Netflix
because I know it didn't start off there
but I think like reach a worldwide
expansion it was through being on a
streaming platform I find it fascinating
the mandalorian I think speaks volumes
to our reaction for episodic versus
serialized storytelling because there
seemed to be this argument I noticed
going around social media effect for the
most part people really love that show
but there seem to be this argument going
around I'd like to get back to the
storyline what is with these one-offs
why is he going about episodic and for
our end we were like well it's a
spaghetti western show and that's kind
of like those western shows back then
right and then lately where we're at in
the show they seem to be tying it all
around even the ones that just felt
episodic they're pulling characters from
there but I found it interesting how
much serialized television has been
associated so strongly with cable and
streaming platforms that you just expect
it to be serialized you don't walk in
unless they really make it clear upfront
you know that this is going to be
episodic television they're not it's not
so much about tying all the episodes but
it's fascinating to know that now we
live in a world where if it's streaming
or cable especially we expect it to be
fully civilized I think on network you
kind of get the lights you realize
because they usually have so many more
episodes that you can't just make them
all connected and tied in serial s
format you got to do some one-off so
you've got a step away from the main
storyline in order to fill your quota of
20 plus episodes where a streaming and
cable lend themselves to a tighter
format because there's usually less
episodes per season yeah one I mean on
cable you also have less commercials
less things to break up the show itself
and on network TV you have so many more
things running in between and
commercials and chaos and more time to
wait because especially now that
everyone's got their streaming platform
up I mean people still release certain
things week by week like the mandalorian
but I mean everything is getting more
and more geared towards binging and
there's all this research about how
Netflix structures their shows to make
you really need to get into that next
episode and watch
two or three at a time they structure
their last like five minutes yeah yeah
but think about those days and and yeah
you know that behind the scenes the math
of even some of the writing and the
structuring is changing to suit
yeah the binge format and so that's an
interesting thing I mean I feel like you
look at a lot of classic shows over time
you have these things that start out
very episodic and then become sort of
pseudo serial over time like your Buffy
or supernatural or a good examples of
that were like the first season you know
it's kind of just like a monster of the
week and then as the show gets picked up
and more fans hop on then it's like well
okay now we got to really dive into our
lead characters people are getting
invested in now so yeah I mean I feel
like both formats are certainly quite
valid and valuable I feel like we've
seen some really great strides in both
camps because I mean the anthology
format has become more popular again
thanks to Black Mirror and I mean you
know I don't know how the twilight zone
reboot is doing but you know things like
that and creep show and American Horror
Story evens like season by season
serialize a episodic seasons and then
you know on the flip side you have all
these other shows that are so involved
in their direct story lies like Breaking
Bad you could have you can count on like
one hand the amount of bottle episodes
there are and the rest are just
continuing this one you know momentous
storylines so yeah it's true well III
think that it's weird when I look at
shows like the flash I don't remember
what season it was there's an episode
that who's the guy who starred in small
soldiers Gregory something oh I almost
remember the name Everwood yeah maybe
anyway it was a big fan back in the day
yeah as in the Patriot 2 7 7 he gets
shot it's bad
but like the flash the CW shows I notice
are often criticized especially because
I think when the Netflix Marvel shows
really came into into play they they're
like made these condense like I forget
how many episodes like 10 to 13 episodes
of like daredevil season 1 and Jessica
Jones and how insanely popular those
shows became and how yeah that was it
was a tightly structured season and
people loved it and then I think that's
one more criticism for the comic book
show started coming out for shows like
arrow or flash any of those I think
Black Lightning Season one had a really
good response because they they didn't
have that many episodes whereas like
flash and arrow get like 24 episodes a
season so a lot of times people like
I've even that one of the people who's
like a reoccurring director on those
shows who have said that they think they
do way too many episodes per season so a
lot of times you got to drag things out
you got stretch things out unnecessarily
or you got to do these one-offs however
a lot of the time those one offs can
sometimes lead to one of the best
episodes you've ever seen Buffy Season 4
had the app had the season with Riley
and the soldiers and that's not a
beloved season but one of the most
beloved episodes of all time from Buffy
is the is the silent episode silence
hush that one yeah where it's pretty
much a silent film and they don't cheer
like a silent film but like everyone's
quiet part of the the thing with the
episode and that is a very beloved
episode within a season that is not
beloved you know and flash at an episode
directed by Gregory Smith I think that's
his name
where flash is that he's trying to stop
a nuclear bomb from going off and he's
just stuck in the flesh I'm not the
flash boys with that Speed Force he's
just stuck in the Speed Force so
everything is just super slow down and
it's it's a problem-solving episode and
it is one of the best episodes of all
the CW shows I've ever seen like it is
truly a fantastic gripping episode that
doesn't succumb to any of its cheese and
that was around the season when you
people like people were complaining
about Flash so the episodic scan
actually allow for subway every once in
a while for those things to go out now
that's not usual though generally
speaking that's that's really not a
common thing usually it's like the
complaints I think are valid I cuz the
other thing too with network television
is I was listening to this podcast with
a were Tina Fey was on Conan O'Brien's a
friend and she was talking about how
they have to really work at structure
because you have to see like when you're
editing the episodes you have to really
make sure it like okay it cuts
commercial at exactly this point yeah
this point and which is a really hard
thing to do you know you're trying to
come compile a perfect scene that could
flow before going to commercial it's a
really challenging task to make sure it
cuts to commercial at the right time so
sometimes you gotta speed up your images
sometimes you gotta make it go like it
like point one percent faster you just
change the front you just change the
speed of the of the clip a little bit
you know so you have these rules to work
around so I think some people might like
it all depends on the on the genre of
the show too and it depends on the style
of the show I think I feel like movies
are trying to become more like TV with
their franchises and TV is becoming more
like cinema which is really cool like TV
has a great rapper and it seems like
there's no shortage of shows getting
greenlit which is fascinating because
now it seems like you can count on that
medium to show you more original ideas
or at least more things that are kind of
different from what you've seen before
and movies are becoming almost slavishly
beholden to you know these through lines
and plot threads and we're gonna keep
these same characters going forever and
it's it's also interesting to watch that
happen across a two-hour format you know
roughly versus you know a forty-five
minute or 60 minute format yeah and yeah
I mean I think that's an interesting
it's an interesting thing to compare
- I mean I think they both have their
place and yeah I can't I can't think of
anything right now I'm sure there are a
ton of examples but just like a pure
lease your episode ik thing anymore
because uh especially in the advent of
all these connected universes and stuff
and all these crossover events I feel
like even shows that are mostly episodic
have started putting in Easter eggs and
cereal elements that come in throughout
I mean it's been that way forever though
I I don't know am any show I can't think
of a show where it's literally pure
purely episodic you know for sure but
there are things that I feel like where
certain things especially like sitcoms
and animated shows would be before I
feel like there are a heavier amount of
callbacks than there used to be well
yeah I mean like it's always something
Philadelphia is often credited as like
one of the the long lasting living sick
sitcom to this day where you can kind of
just hop in at any point but even then I
feel like you don't get the full of
pretty vanilla semi serialized friends
semi sort of Seinfeld even which is
something that's really quite for
definitely serialized Curb Your
Enthusiasm is another one where there's
there are its tie-in elements per per
season so literally unless it's an
anthology show like a black mirror I
think that's when it's only pure
episodic but it's like it depends on the
kind of show like if you have your chill
out relax hang back kind of shows like
your friends I prefer light serialized
as a per as opposed to you know watching
The Watchmen series and I'm like I got a
really details Reds but then again
there's show there's a comedies like I
just I'm John like I think the most
underrated comedy on television
currently is Silicon Valley surprisingly
I don't hear many people talk about it I
don't see it on many lists and there
didn't seem to me much hype towards this
last season but I think is one of the
best comedies ever
and it's a very serialize show like I
need to watch the recaps in order to
make sure I'm not missing anything or
ever like whenever they start a new
episode I need to pay attention to the
recap and I think that's really cool to
do a show to do a comedy show like that
that really depends on paying attention
heavily to the storyline yeah definitely
but I think with comedies like Silicon
Valley what they often do is usually
it's like water a few characters are
very serialize and then you got a couple
of other ones who are just there for you
know the funny and the episodic
funniness the weak nature yeah yeah
exactly but then you got a few words a
really really connective tissue per
episode per season I think my right now
I prefer serialized of course I feel
like most of us do it's more rewarding
in a sense but when I just want to kick
back and have fun and like yeah I don't
just want a snack yeah I prefer my light
my lights that feel so much serialize
television I really got it I got be on
the TV and I gotta have my undivided
attention or also want to miss some [ __ ]
and I got to keep consistent otherwise
I'm gonna fall off this video finishes
but yeah you want these like CW shows I
can just casually watch them and I don't
have to worry about especially because
the lights serialized ones usually
because of its commercial breaks and the
fact that their weekly usually have like
this heavy exposition to remind you of
these rely on their recaps a really yeah
it's all there in that episode to really
remind you so that more as like
serialized TV doesn't use like hard
course you realize doesn't usually do
that because it's so about paying
attention to every episode and like one
will say because they respect their
audience but it's also like some shows
are designed for those people who come
home off of work and then watched on
network TV and then those other shows
that are designed more for the binge
format and I think that's why I bring it
back to Mandalorian for being on a
streaming platform I think that's why
they're doing kind of a hybrid because
they're releasing it weekly that they're
doing a little
both and I find an impressive when
there's cable shows that still commit to
this format like I just finished
Watchmen last night and that's a show
you gotta pay attention to every every
bleeding second of a series of up until
the last minute and and and the fact
that you tune in weekly my preference is
not the binge watching shows my
preference is more of the watchman where
it's serialize format but it's weekly
yeah time to digest the thickness of the
last episode before you move into the
next one yeah cuz I feel like Ben shows
you the ones that are does not like
Netflix which I think even though shows
will stretch things out and not properly
conclude a lot of their episodes because
they specifically will design them for
when it says next episode in five
seconds I prefer you not to click off
because a lot of the times I notice like
the cliffhangers are not that strong the
more like oh the scenes not finished
finish that scene and that's a good
reason to come back lead version of the
scene yeah where I think sir Eli's
weekly shows don't do that
they end they complete that episode and
they then they move on to the next one
whereas some of these binging streaming
shows and I love a lot of them I do I'm
not complaining about it necessarily
like like I don't like them but a lot of
these serialized binge shows they just
throw complete the rebus it's that way
you watch the next one one finds them in
episodes start to get blurry in when
you're binging at a high rate because
then you think back in your like what
episode did this event happen on I had a
lot of that when we were watching
stranger things this last season because
I had just caught up on the second
season right before filming and so all
these details were like running together
in my mind across like what happened in
which season leading up to when so I do
appreciate the time between especially
some serialize things because yeah it
does give those a bit of time to
solidify and germinate in your mind
well yeah I mean I think like Horning of
Hill houses as a major exception to what
I'm talking about
that was a binge show on Netflix but I
think the thing that really separated
from the rest was the fact that they
were all directed by one guy and I think
that's what often gets lost in binging
is you'd have a it can be challenging to
truly differentiate the specialty of the
episode they often get jumbled into just
one season and as opposed to it's like
because there's something to be said for
the binging format they are a very long
movie sometimes so they're telling this
whole story one like that serialize a
serialize do they're pretty unified that
way yeah but like when we watch keep
keep using the mandalorian me because
the show we're watching right now but
also because it does both
mandalorian like I remember each episode
and I can usually remember who directed
what episode because they all have their
own kind of flavor to it
yeah not everyone but wood hunting a
hill house is one of the rare shows
where the every episode is directed by
the same guy whereas a lot of these bin
shows there's a different director per
episode we might remember very specific
sequences or when this crazy sequence
went down in this episode but the
episode as a whole can be forgotten yeah
and the authorship that comes with that
I would imagine because yeah Hill House
is an interesting one I find it
interesting that I think that show as
well as the Mandalorian separate their
episodes by quote chapters because
especially Hill House and Mandalorian to
they do feel each like their own little
chapter and they have sort of a
crispness because Hill House yeah is
like a really see realized story across
two timelines and yet each episode does
feel distinct because it they have that
motif to where you're focusing on a
specific member of the family in each
episode and so that even sets up an
interesting take on the episodic and
serialized blend because you know it's
sort of episodic in terms of
you're focusing on but totally cereal in
terms of the context yeah and I like
seeing things like that I like seeing
shows Bend and mashed together the
format's yeah you know just create new
feeling flavors I guess yeah because I I
loved the shows where every episode has
a true beginning middle and an end
yeah that's not to say I don't like
cliff hangers I love cliff hangers my
point earlier about how some like I
really notice it in daredevil season two
I've just like don't like is at that
point if it's like every episode it
starts to become a math problem more
than a structural you know natural thing
because I think network TV episodic TV
will have their cliff hangers and I love
a lost really hinged off of its cliff
hangers yeah so I think cliff hangers
are are great if utilized properly
because you can still do a complete
episode and have a cliffhanger it shows
like Barry I'm just waiting for that
third season because and you're not
fully caught up but the way that second
season ended great cliffhanger but I
still felt like the episode was complete
complete you know so yeah my general my
main preference is serialized TV but
weekly broken up or if they all did a
kind of haunting a hill house thing on
these binging shows yeah because I can
really remember each episode of haunting
of Hill House was like eight or nine not
a lot n 10 of patan episodes but you
know like Egypt because the fact you're
cutting around it and a lot of times
like shows like honey Hill house will
focus on a specific character per
episode yeah a lot of these bin shows
are cutting around every one per episode
yeah
difficult to remember you know yeah man
that's the thing is too is I feel like
now that we live in a giant archive you
notice that things do get more and more
serialize because people are more and
more meticulous about notes and details
of shows it's like you think back to the
old idea of what a convention used to be
like and you
think of like the Star Trek fan being
like an episode 508 yeah and I feel like
maybe we are more into serial television
as a whole now because those details
won't get lost as easily you don't have
to wait a century for a show to come out
on DVD if they decide you are successful
enough to release now everything is kind
of here and once it's released it's
there forever and so there's not the
same level of memory or attention span
but yeah yeah I definitely appreciate
both formats but I'm always very
enthralled when somebody can complete a
very satisfying serial story arc
especially just like a really crisp
season yeah that's that's you know as
somebody who wants to write as well you
know that's a that's the format I would
want to go toward but I would like to
master the episodic as well I mean yeah
I think I think Dex like Dexter was the
first truly sir realized hell of it his
dead Dexter
watchman has a similar effect Oh without
that ended of like they really ended it
and to the point where if they want to
end the show they can't they really can
just go alright no I'm done like the
show was a major hit every time I wear
my watchman sweater there's someone who
I've never met who will just be like you
watching the show like it's a it's a big
show but they can end it if they want
Dexter season one had that as well where
you're like we're they over mirror and
then they not having a lot of amazing
seasons to follow where each season felt
like a sequel to the last that's I
wonder if Dexter had anything to do with
the changing I mean it was obviously
when real prestige TV started to take
hold I remember Dexter was one of those
shows everyone was talking about and
that's got a procedural element and one
thing I don't feel like and I don't
watch as much network TV so it could be
just the same as it was ever but I feel
like there are less of those like CSI
type just the different crime every week
sort of episode they still exist
they still exist but they're not the
zeitgeist yes there was a time where
like every network had like four of them
and then four versions of the medical
approach to that and now I feel like
it's very much like what's the hook
what's the story gonna be about over the
season well I think like I think
Sopranos opened the door yeah yeah yeah
soprano and then what was the show
before Sopranos there's surprised wire
before surprise the what yeah I was one
of those shows right everyone always
talks first liar oh oh yeah I figured I
forget the or a prison break
HBO open the door yeah but I think when
she won Showtime when they showed that
another net another cable service can do
it sometimes it's like okay that's their
thing it's not TV it's HBO what like yes
sounds like that's their thing but when
they would when another person can
proved they can do it also but in their
own way or am see suddenly and
everyone's trying to do it you know so I
think it really put a cloud over certain
network TV because yeah I don't really
hear unless it's already had a built-in
fan base for a long time like [ __ ]
you know Grey's Anatomy or supernatural
you know yeah I remember back in the day
I used to always be aware of like oh
we're the new shows coming on which
one's gonna stink and now I see a
billboard or a bus stop at every now and
again for like whiskey Tango but like
you know never really anything that I
hear about from anybody else well we
like our rated television - I think we I
think for dramas we like when they push
the boundaries in terms of what you can
like the violence and stuff so that was
I remember - yeah when especially around
the time like Mad Men was big and there
was some other stuff going on there were
Network shows trying to make content
that would approach that level but you
can but you can't yeah you're sitting
there going you're teasing all this like
you know sex and mischief and intrigue
but I know it's gonna be TV 14 at the
most and you're not gonna be able to
approach what these cable networks do
yeah and I feel like that conundrum is
interesting for the network environment
yeah yeah sometimes I shows like NYPD
Blue could get away with more or
Criminal Minds I always heard was like
particularly messed up in terms because
they ever got like 10 p.m.
yeah
with the this is when kids should be
asleep that's what society deems when
time actually mattered to your
entertainment schedule it is a
fascinating time when honestly when I
first got this request I was like what
the hell are we talking about and then I
found serious butter actually a lot to
explore here within this one topic yeah
or maybe we just beat topics is death
it's just a cool Venn diagram alright
guys well what are your thoughts on this
topic what do you prefer what do you
miss about the the olden days of
television what do you prefer about
today personally I think streaming is
beautiful I think it's I think it's hurt
a lot in certain ways but I think it's
also about a mate like the fact of how
many like there's exciting window oh my
god they have a season of television out
on DVD but now it's you know like all
these shows you couldn't watch before or
now unlike so many streaming services
which is so all like that's awesome cuz
it's because so many shows took all
years and years and years of hard work
but then they just got lost
yeah and now now you can watch them have
an archive in your pocket on your desk
where you up almost anything at any
moment that's that's my favorite thing
about it yeah like I know there's all
the new shows and stuff but my favorite
thing is how much can be preserved now
yeah it's all part of the evolution and
it's interesting to see because some
some things will have to either fall by
the wayside or become less prevalent in
the process which does affect you know
people's livelihood in a way but from
the yeah macro point of view it is just
the evolution of the media ya know
people can compete for the highest
bidder on friends I mean whatever
streaming service wants it now alright
guys well leave your thoughts down below
Thanks Omni media so much man thanks
Michael you rock my friend I love your
Star Wars review seriously just go check
out his channel
I don't read jokes about it was just
gosh is it really is he really he's like
there are times John and I are just
setting up stuff and we just like play
his video and we listen to it are they
we've done that many times we're just
listening to what he's talking about it
so holding each other and weeping yeah